on essaie de faire tous les choses aussi
de faire pendant ma jeunesse on ce soir
ça n'a pas fonctionné
ça commence quand vous l'êtes et
pourtant les josefin ont tout tenté à
l'image de jeanne rose et de telle est
sous le regard attentif de vrais
supporters les étoiles d'or comment ce
festival à trois points
vincent puis le capitaine des ça c'est
beau c'est très beau en jambes et
confiant les étoiles dans augmentent
leur capital points
les rouges tiennent le coup lolliot à
sur ces deux points sous la raquette
combatif et décidé les gold and his de
fort de france pousse trop brillant avec
ce panier permet à son équipe d'arriver
à la pause avec aux points d'avance le
temps de communiquer le score sur le
parquet les jeux effet alors mené pousse
et ça passe
les fouilles à l'est dans la foulée
répondent trop de pertes de balles
joséphine fond de france en profite et
inscrit deux points de plus fausse
courage envie de vaincre le golden star
excellent tout lui réussit
les josefin ne lâche rien telle est fait
son mieux mais c'est trop tard
les joueurs du tandem susic qui
squattent ses poses 86 à 41
bon ça peut parler pour cette finale en
sachant que
il y aura toujours les connu de la
chance qui frappe je souris ou pas donc
voilà en tout cas on va travailler
encore pour être bien aux conditions la
finale face à la gauloise de qualité
juste après la finale féminine est clair
de rivière salée golden star et ce sera
à louis achille samedi